glauben sie an gott falls jahres halbfas
nein bedauern sie ihre ungläubigkeit
oder halten sie sich als gottlose person
für besonders frei heute diskutieren der
sternstunde philosophie die
gretchenfrage im vorfeld haben wir ein
paar leute gefragt ob sie an gott
glauben ja
warum wir eine höhere macht da geht
einem kraftakt im z
ich sähe gut er in der natur realen
summen aus als innere also in figur
vielleicht bürger als krise trennt seine
leber gott glaubt ist es anfangs sehr
schwierig also bestellte bis materials
das ist uns in äußert sich in jedem land
jeder man sich nicht materiell festlegen
es ist so einfach da ist und der glaube
ist gut
ob es philosophisch betrachtet sinnvoll
sein kann an gott zu glauben diskutiere
ich heute mit meinen gästen
das ist zum einen holt ins ist professor
für theoretische philosophie an der
freien universität in berlin
er outet sich zum großen erstaunen
vieler kollegen in seinem neuesten buch
auf gottes gläubiger und ich diskutiere
mit philipp oebel junior professor für
politische philosophie an der
universität stuttgart
er bezeichnet sich als atheisten
herzlich willkommen
ja ja übel wenn gott morgen vom himmel
stieg
und das würde sich herausstellen er
existiert doch wären sie schockiert oder
erleichtert ich finde das gar nicht so
schlimm
ich glaube zwar dass es sehr
unwahrscheinlich ist dass das passiert
russell hat dazu was sie nicht gesagt er
würde dann zu gott sagen du hättest mehr
hinweise geben sollen und ich denke
ähnlich ich war positiv überrascht
sagen wir mal so die hinweise haben also
bis anhin nicht ausgereicht hertens wenn
sie noch sterben und es stellt sich
heraus da ist kein gott
wie reagieren sie gar nicht fand ich das
nicht mitbekommen würde und hätte ihn in
ihr glaube dann dennoch was gebraucht
ja nicht gerne ja
die hoffnung ist einfach sehr wichtig
und man verfehlt sein oder verfälscht
sein leben nicht wenn man wenn sich
herausstellt dass es gott nicht gibt man
aber in seinem leben an gott geglaubt
oder auf gott vertraut hat man könnte
das aussehen an besonders
eindrucksvollen beispielen nehmen sie
mal edith stein die juden die zum
katholizismus übergetreten ist sie in
ein kloster gegangen ist und die dann in
auschwitz umgebracht worden ist wir
wissen von ihr dass sie in den letzten
tagen ihres lebens sich intensiv
gekümmert hat um die verfolgten juden
die nach auschwitz abtransportiert
wurden
und man kann ja nicht sagen die hat ihr
leben verpfuscht selbst wenn sich
herausstellt dass sie im grunde genommen
in einer illusion gestorben ist
dieses jahr vom ersten zum testen
geworden haben sich sozusagen geoutet
was hat diese kehrtwende verursacht bei
ihnen das kann ich gar nicht genau sagen
viele freunde sagen natürlich das hängt
mit dem alter zusammen und ich will das
nicht völlig in abrede stellen das kann
ein stück weit auch eine rolle spielen
ich bin vor allen dingen als philosoph
wieder zum gottes gedanken zurückgekehrt
in dem sinne dass ich sage man darf den
gottes gedanken ernst nehmen und man
muss ihn auch philosophisch ernst nehmen
das ist im grunde genommen die größte
wandlung die ich durchgemacht habe
ich wüsste gar nicht ob ich mich als
gott gläubig bezeichnen sollte ich würde
sagen ich bin ein philosoph bleibe ein
philosoph aber ein philosoph der den
gottes gedanken ernst nehmen sie mal die
geschichte der philosophie die in der
geschichte der philosophie haben alle
denker bis hebel
denn gottes gedanken ernst genommen und
haben im grunde genommen gesagt wir
können die welt und uns gar nicht
richtig und angemessen verstehen wenn
wir nicht gott hin zu denken und also
den gottes gedanken nehmen wir hier
jetzt auch noch ernst wollen den
diesen gedanken auch mal so richtig
durch diskutieren
interessant ist aber schon dass in ihrem
buch auch sagen ein philosoph heute der
sich mit der gottesfrage auseinander
setzt sich dieser frage stellt und sie
eigentlich auch positiv beantwortet
dafür müssen wir schon sagen dieses buch
ein versuch über rationale theologie ist
eine verpflichtung des nachdenkens über
gott und auch der sache gottes ein
zoobesuch dass er das tut der ist heute
irgendwie unter druck da wird kritisiert
und stellt sich so ein bisschen die
frage ob das nicht so was ähnliches wie
man sich ihn stellen würde uns sagen
frau holle ist ein real existierendes
lesen ist das das gleiche herr hebel
das glaube ich nicht dass was gleich er
ist also es gibt sicherlich so einem
philosophischen mainstream die meisten
versuchen wird wahrscheinlich eher
atheistische sind aber dass man über die
gottesfrage sozusagen mit rationalen
argumenten sprechen kann und muss das
halte ich auch für gegeben und es gibt
natürlich in dieser diskussion
vielleicht einige positionen die sind
ein bisschen diesen er so absurd oder
ein bisschen schwächer positioniert die
kommen er dann vielleicht auch so einer
religiösen theologischen positionen aber
so eine art rationale theologie dass man
sich fragt welche argumente könnten
dafür sprechen haben philosophen seit
den anfängen gemacht und halte ich auch
für sinnvoll da muss einfach nur fragen
wer am ende die besten argumente
was spricht darüber sprechen wir gleich
aber vielleicht ist es doch noch
sprechen wer ist eigentlich gott wer ist
gott für sie hätten sich das einlesen
zudem anbieten kann
ja das ist ein lesen sollte man beten
kann ich habe eine ganz traditionelle
vorstellung von gott die auch in der
philosophie immer wieder vertreten wurde
gott ist ein unendlicher geist und
vollkommener geist also es vergleich bei
uns wir sind ich subjekte wir können so
muss ich sagen so stelle ich mir gott
auch vor und dann hat er bestimmte
vollkommenheit eigenschaften
er denkt vollkommen es allwissend es
allmächtig er ist vollkommen vernünftig
und vollkommen gut das heißt gott denkt
gott denkt das heißt das selbe wie es
was es auch bei uns
sie wissen von im eigenen vom eigenen
fall was es heißt an gedanken zu
durchdenken und aufgrund eines gedankens
einer einsicht zu gewinnen und dann
aufgrund dieses gedankens etwas zu
wissen und das sind sätze prädikate die
wir auch gott zu sprechen dürfen
herr übel für sie vollkommen absurd also
vollkommen ab sofort kann man nicht
sagen aber ich glaube erst mal aus
meiner position heraus dass nicht so
viel dafür spricht dass anzunehmen ich
glaube ich das ist absurd ist dass
anzunehmen dass es nicht irgendwie in
sich widersprüchlich als es auf jeden
fall eine logische möglichkeit aber ich
frage mich bei sowas immer warum also
welche motivation sollte ich haben
zuallererst seine annahme zu machen und
eine möglichkeit könnte sein um zu
erklären warum es überhaupt die welt
existiert dass er gott so eine art
schöpfer ist ein anderes grund könnte
sein dass man sagt bewusst sein dass wir
menschen ich subjekte sind wir
bewusstsein haben ist irgendwie ein
rätsel
und wir können das nicht irgendwie
erklären was ist irgendwie
naturwissenschaftlich nicht einholbar
das könnten gründe seien das anzunehmen
aber ist noch nicht richtig glauben
spricht mehr dafür lieber in solchen
fällen zu sagen wir wissen einiges nicht
und einige rätsel werden vielleicht auch
nie gelöst werden als zusätzlich noch
die annahme zu machen dass da so eine
höhere unendlicher geist sie haben sich
in ihrem buch folge den weißen kaninchen
gibt es einen kapitel über gott und
beschreiben sie ja wie sie als kind
durchaus offen waren für touristische
vorstellungen und irgendwann ziemlich
erleichtert waren was man daran ja gar
nicht glauben muss gibt es keine
situation die sich heute ausdenken
können sie denken na ja irgendwie hat es
für mich doch viel mich in eine ethische
richtung weiterzuentwickeln
da habe ich mich wirklich sehr weit
davon entfernt also das ist natürlich
schwer das zu rekonstruieren aber ich
kann das so ungefähr so auf die zeit als
ich so 13 14 war das war die zeit als
ich zum gymnasium immer so ein
spaziergang gemacht habe
vom schulweg und da hab ich mir relativ
viel gedanken darüber gemacht hatten
noch religionsunterricht
das interessiert mich auch noch gut
sagen thematisch bis heute aber ich
hatte immer so diese angst vielleicht
habe das auch andere kinder oder
jugendlichen dass gott mir vielleicht zu
hören
könnte ja ich dachte immer egal was ich
mache er weiß ja was ich denke und tue
und das war so ein bisschen beklemmendes
gefühl und irgendwann hatte ich dieses
hatte ich mich kam diese überlegung auf
vielleicht hört ja keiner zu ja warum
soll ich überhaupt angehen dass da einer
zuhört welche gründe habe ich eigentlich
dass also so philosophisch habe ich
nicht in mir formuliert aber so würde
ich das wort rekonstruieren und das habe
ich so ein bisschen als erleichterung
empfunden mir keiner zuhört und ich
denken kann was ich will ist das
erleichtern kann auch tröstlich sein in
einer zu wird klar also aus heutiger
sicht würde ich sagen es gibt sehr viele
positive merkmale die man auch verbinden
kann das jetzt sozusagen nur meine
persönliche wie kann man das sagen
bekehrung zum atheismus hier denen
niemand zu verticken wird gott sie das
weiß ich ich habe gott mich hört das ist
auch nicht die frage die für mich im
mittelpunkt steht sondern zunächst
einmal muss man und da stimme ich ein
hügel zu es ist eine kühne annahme die
wir machen eine man könnte sagen soll
eine art rahmen annahme oder
weltanschauliche rahmen annahme die auch
nicht bewiesen werden kann sondern die
eben einen rahmen abgibt und wir
versuchen dann unser leben und unsere
erfahrungen unsere gedanken zu
interpretieren im lichte dieser rahmen
annahme deshalb gibt es keinen beweis
für die existenz konnte ich glaube an
keinen einzigen gottesbeweis der in der
philosophie vorgelegt worden ist
es ist eine sehr kühne these aber ich
erlaube mir darauf hinzuweisen dass es
auch eine andere sehr kühne these gibt
nämlich die these dass es nur diesen
materielle erfahrungswelt gibt so wie
sie von den wissenschaften von den
naturwissenschaften beschrieben wird und
sonst nichts das ist auch eine these die
weit über das hinausgeht was wir wissen
und wissen können sondern sie liegen ja
sogar noch einen drauf sie sagen das ist
auch eine metaphysische position
herr über ihre position sie sind ein
sogenannter naturalist was glauben sie
ich würde mich also man hat also punkt
eins naturalismus das kann sehr vieles
heißen philosophie ich habe mich glaube
ich bisher als natur alles selber
bezeichnet da müsste man immer noch mal
schauen was man genau damit unter
versteht
aber es ist natürlich richtig dass jede
annahme die man über die weltmacht immer
ein metaphysisches oder also kann man
auch sagen ontologische anderen
sozusagen beinhaltet nämlich dass man
sich auf irgendwas festlegen muss zum
beispiel was es gibt ja auch der atheist
sagt es gibt materie planeten
naturgesetze vielleicht oder naturkräfte
also man kommt darum drum nicht herum
denn es gibt keine metaphysik freie
wissenschaft dass wir mal zugestehen
genau weil mit metaphysiker gemeint ist
im traditionellen sinne die wissenschaft
davon was existiert oder vielleicht auch
die die natur der dinge ist und jeder
der irgendetwas sagt legt sich darauf
fest dass irgendwas existiert wenn ich
sage ich habe hier ein glas wasser mich
da raus was trinken habe ich mich schon
auf die existenz des glases wasser das
wasser glases festgelegt und genau so
legt sich auch ein atheist darauf fest
dass irgendwas existiert er macht halt
den sozusagen der zieht die linie bei
dem punkt wo es darum geht ob gott noch
zudem existiert das ist in der welt gibt
aber ich frage mich ob man so weit gehen
dass man sagt es existiert nur das was
die naturwissenschaften festlegen also
in dem punkt bin ich nicht naturalist
dass ich sage alles was in der ganzen
welt existiert lässt sich zurückführen
auf die grundannahmen die
naturwissenschaften getroffen werden ja
also wir bestehen nur aus
elementarteilchen das da würde ich sagen
bin ich anti naturalist weil wenn das
heißt ich muss mich auf die
naturwissenschaftlerin sage alle
wissenschaften zusammen beschreiben die
welt so wie sie ist und darüber hinaus
gibt es nichts würde ich sagen
in dem punkt bin ich sozusagen weit
gefasster naturalist das klingt mir
jetzt aber ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen
harmlose so was wie ich setze jetzt fest
hier dieses glas existiert dieses blatt
existiert die küche existieren sie
existieren und dann kompetenz und er
sagt es existiert noch gott noch so eins
oben drauf aber so klein ist die
differenz ja dann doch nicht genau die
ist nicht für alles was man annimmt was
existiert meistens setzt man es gar
nicht fest sondern unterstellt ist nur
für alle annahmen die man macht braucht
man gute gründe und ich finde ein
starkes argument in der geschichte des
orkans rasiermesser oder hans klingl das
ist ein prinzip der wissenschaften dass
man seinen seien es nicht vermehrt oder
man könnte auch sagen dass man
immer die einfachste erklärung die beste
ist also die mit den wenigsten annahmen
über existierende objekte auskommt und
da würde ich sagen
gewinnt der grobe oder weit gefasst
naturalismus weil ja sagt es gibt alles
so in der welt aber es gibt darüber
hinaus nicht noch etwas und wenn man
sagt es gibt noch einen führen geist
oder ein höheres wesen da muss man gute
gründe haben für diese zusatz annahme
das problem ist eher dass wir begreifen
müssen wie es sein kann dass es
einerseits die materielle erfahrungswelt
gibt wie sie durch die wissenschaften
beschrieben wird und andererseits uns
als geistige wesen gibt die zu sich
selbst ich sagen können die eben diese
materielle erfahrungswelt erkennen und
die nicht nur dieses erkennen sondern
die auch wissen dass sie sind die diese
materielle erfahrungswelt erkennen und
wir müssen uns einen reim darauf machen
können wie das beides zusammen passen
kann
und wenn sie schon zugestehen dass wir
als geistige wesentlich reduziert werden
können oder hergeleitet werden können
aus dem materiellen dann geben sie im
grunde genommen schon einen ganz
wichtigen schritt gehen sie schon im
grunde genommen einen ganz wichtigen
schritt sie geben schon etwas zu nämlich
dass die these dass die welt von
elementarteilchen also von materiellen
im innersten zusammen gehalten wird
eigentlich so nicht stimmen kann
denn es gibt noch etwas es gibt uns als
geistige wesen und offensichtlich können
wir nicht vollständig auf das materielle
reduziert werden so dass wir zumindest
eine form von dualismus haben ja und
dualismus hat immer eine schwierigkeit
dualismus hat immer die schwierigkeit zu
verstehen warum das beides zusammen
auftreten
sie sagen der film genommen der der
reine material ist also leute die
gerhard roth beispielsweise die das
ganze hier so erklären dass man sagt das
sind alles nur neuronale impulse und
strukturen physikalische strukturen
das ist sozusagen die richtige
gegenposition verlieren aber eigentlich
macht er übel schon einen schritt in
ihre
es sind schon gemäßigt weil er eben arm
nimmt bewusstsein ist was anderes und
dann muss ja hügel dieses andere
erklären können ganz einfach gesagt
haben wir drei möglichkeiten
wir haben die möglichkeit sozusagen
alles ist materie das ist die position
des naturalismus wir haben die
möglichkeit es gibt materie und
geistiges in gestalt von uns person das
ist eine spielart des so genannten dual
is muss oder wir haben eine zweite
sogenannte monastische position die also
diese zweiheit loswerden will und das
ist der idealismus er sagt dass der
geist ist es der die welt im innersten
zusammenhält und sie sind die die an ist
ich bin in diesem sinne idealist auf die
frage was hält die welt im innersten
zusammen würde ich gerne die antwort
geben
es ist nicht sinnlose blinde für moral
und glück und geistiges blinde materie
und blinde naturgesetze die die welt im
innersten zusammenhalten sondern es ist
vernunft es ist geist und ein christ
würde vielleicht noch hin zu setzen
es ist liebe bleibt jetzt bot extrakt
ich jetzt kommt dem spiel hatten
der kommt genau dadurch ins spiel dass
man sagt die welt als etwas zu begreifen
dem geist zu grunde liegt lässt sich
wiederum philosophisch betrachtet nur
vernünftig denken wenn man denkt dass
diese welt eine geistige schöpfung
gottes ist und die primäre realität ist
jetzt sehen sie ganz deutlich das
geistige und nicht etwas materielles und
ziehen sie in diesem sinne journalist
das weiß sachen die passiert hat und die
ihm zugewiesen
ich würde behaupten es gibt vielleicht
noch mehrere zwischenposition oder
spielarten des dualismus also was sie
angesprochen haben ist ja dieses
klassische leib seele problem eigentlich
das manchmal jetzt so neumodisch das
hautproblem genannt wird wie kann
bewusstsein oder eine ich perspektive
aus der materiellen welt entstehen ja
alle moleküle und elektronen aus denen
die welt geschaffen es habe keinen
bewusstsein keine ich-perspektive wir
menschen haben die schon wir besteht aus
molekülen
aber nichts an den molekülen kann
irgendwie uns verständlich machen wieso
wir diese subjektive ich perspektive
haben und das würde ich auch sagen
das größte rätsel der wissenschaft weil
die ich-perspektive an uns als personen
gebunden ist die wissenschaft hat eine
objektive beschreibung perspektive und
die können ja wenig zusammen bringen
deshalb habe ich einmal scherzhaft
glaube ich auch in dem buch gesagt eine
position die man da vertreten kann es
die ich habe keine ahnung position
ich habe viele philosophen vertreten die
ohne das so explizit zu benennen weil
die einfach sagen bewusstsein ist ein
rätsel keiner weiß wie es in die welt
gekommen ist würde ich auch so sehen
aber ich glaube nicht dass mich das
darauf verpflichtet dann zu sagen dann
muss ich auch an nehmt also sowas gibt
wie in unendlichen geist ich finde man
kann auch sagen es gibt unlösbare rätsel
oder zumindest dem ersten anschein nach
unlösbare rätsel ohne dass man so weit
gehen muss zu sagen da dann bin ich
eigentlich in irgendeiner form schon auf
dem weg zum gottesglauben haben sie am
anfang gesagt eine schwierigkeit ist
natürlich immer für den autisten zu
erklären die eigentlich alles angefangen
hatten dass sich also einer der
klassischen gottes beweise der
kosmologische gottesbeweis der unbewegte
bewege bei aristoteles später war von
thomas von aquin wieder aufgenommen also
diese frage wenn man alles mit
naturgesetzen erklären will und mit
physikalischen tatsachen
wir hatten eigentlich angefangen die
sache dazu bewegen wer hat die
naturgesetze angestoßen die athens sagen
aber sehr klar gottes beweise halte ich
für humbug da oder zumindest der bau ich
meine theologie nicht darauf ist doch
eigentlich ein kluger gottes bereich
nicht ein kluger gottesbeweis sondern es
ist eben ein vernünftiger und ernst zu
nehmender gedanke dass man sich klar
machen muss wir verstehen im grunde
genommen nicht wirklich wer wir sind
wenn wir annehmen es gibt nur materie
und natürlich kann man sich auf den
standpunkt von einem hügel stellen den
zusammenhang zwischen dem materiellen
und dem geistigen verstehen wir nicht
und das wird ein ewiges rätsel bleiben
das ist übrigens auch im grunde genommen
natürlich keine besonders angenehme
auskunft denn ist es komisch dass in
dieser materiellen welt dann
offensichtlich geistige wesen entstehen
die die fähigkeit haben über das
materielle hinauszudenken sich als von
dem materiellen unterschieden zu
begreifen aber nicht begreifen wieso sie
in dieser materiellen welt aufkommen und
müssen dann so ist ja die vorstellung
von herrn hübel jedenfalls irgendwann
sterben wie wir alle sterben müssen und
das war es dann
und sie nehmen jeder von uns nimmt diese
frage wieso gab es uns und wieso gibt es
dieses geheimnis von materie und geist
müssen sie mit ins grab nehmen und das
ist jedenfalls bevor ich das denke ja
bevor ich das denken und mich damit
abfinden untersuche ich und denke ich
lieber noch mal über die alternativen
optionen nach und wir haben eine weitere
alternative option
und das ist im grunde genommen
irgendeine spielart des touristischen
idealismus und die finde ich erst einmal
vom gedanken her eine außerordentlich
attraktive position
ich habe vorhin bisschen gelacht dass er
gesagt hat naja
dies darf sich so tröstlich bei mir wäre
das ist ja mal sowas one film ein
argument überzeugen und war nicht also
ich finde es auch tröstlicher wenn ich
wenn ich nicht recht hätte aber ich kann
mich selber nicht dazu bringen es gibt
also mechanismen der selbsttäuschung
dass man sich vielleicht dann sozusagen
wunschdenken was man sich so lange das
was man wünscht einredet dass man es
tatsächlich für wahr hält das bei mir
funktioniert das nicht so richtig also
ich sehe den punkt dass das keine schöne
zukunft ist ja das ist sozusagen auf
grund dieses existenzialismus dass mit
dem tod alles vorbei ist und selbst wenn
wir etwas hinterlassen wenn die
zeitspanne groß genug macht wird in 1000
jahren oder eine million jahren wird das
universum wahrscheinlich existieren aber
es würden keine spur mehr von uns zurück
bleiben wenn man sich das manchmal so
klar macht dass erschütternd aber ich
habe es noch nicht geschafft sozusagen
davon
nicht da darin zu beruhigen indem ich
irgendwie zu gott gekommen wenn also
mich hinter überzeugen die argumente
immer noch nicht obwohl es besser wäre
wenn sie mich überzeugen würde dann
würde ich sicherlich dass bei angenehmer
aber sie müssen glaube ich wegkommen von
der von dem gedanken dass gott zu denken
gleichbedeutend ist mit wunschdenken das
ja eine ganze das wollte ich nicht sagen
aber form der kritik
lassen sie uns darauf später
zurückkommen aber ich möchte etwas noch
besser verstehen sie verwahren sich auch
jetzt vorhin als ich sie gefragt habe
gegen die idee eines gottes beweises sie
sagen aber trotzdem irgendwie
vernünftiger mit gott zu rechnen oder
gott zu denken
sie sind logiker
wissenschaftstheoretiker warum ist der
beweis nicht angebracht ein beweis für
die für das dasein gottes geht so sie
haben prämisse voraussetzung raus
setzungen und zeigen wenn diese
voraussetzungen war sind dann existiert
gott dann gibt es gott mit den logos
eigenschenk tja das ist dann eine
logische konsequenz dieser voraussetzung
und in der prämisse wird über gott
geredet ich gehe ganz anders vor und
weltanschauliche rahmen annahmen können
auch nicht bewiesen werden durch etwas
sondern die werden vorausgesetzt und
dann schaut man welche konsequenzen
haben die und man kann verschiedene
rahmen annahmen auf ihre konsequenzen
hin durch denken ja und dann stellen
sich unterschiede heraus also die eine
position kommt mit bestimmten erfahrung
mit bestimmten phänomenen gut zurecht
die anderen andere position hat
außerordentliche schwierigkeiten und
jetzt liegt deshalb kein wunschdenken
vor weil diese rahmen annahmen weder
bewiesen noch widerlegt werden können
sondern nur auf ihre konsequenzen hin
durchdacht werden können und dann stellt
sich aber heraus vergleiche ich zum
beispiel die touristische rahmen annahme
mit der des naturalismus es gibt nur das
materielle durch naturgesetze bestimmte
dann stellt sich heraus dass diese
naturalistische position in wahrheit
große probleme hat sie wird mit vielen
phänomenen nicht fertig sie hat zum
beispiel die frage
sie muss annehmen dass ist jedenfalls
die heutige leseart man hält sich an die
ergebnisse der wissenschaft hält man
sich an die ergebnisse der
wissenschaften kommt raus also es gab
eine urknall situation und aus der
urknall situation hat sich unser
physikalisches universum entwickelt
frage ist natürlich und wie ist die
urknall situation entstanden die unten
bewegte belege kommt ja doch wieder ins
spiel
und wie hat man sich die fundamentalen
naturgesetze zu denken warum sind die so
wie sie sind was mich noch einen
gedanken zu ende führen und jetzt sagt
man im rahmen dieser touristischen
annahme haben diese fragen eine antwort
während der naturalist in wahrheit keine
antwort hatte er muss sagen ich muss die
fundamentalen naturgesetze so hinnehmen
wie sie sind sie sind nun mal so und wie
ist die urknall situation entstanden
weiß ich nicht muss ich so hinnehmen
muss ich einfach als man muss sich
einfach hinnehmen hier endet unser
erklären aber ganz schön gepunktet
erheben
ich glaube das stimmt dass unser
erklären endet aber wir müssen uns damit
abfinden
es gibt zwei große rätsel einmal warum
das universum existiert also was vor dem
urknall war keiner kann sich das
vorstellen ob so oft einen hervor geben
kann ob derzeit dimensionen da waren und
wie bewusstsein entstanden ist ich
glaube nur nicht dass es zu der zu
diesem großen rätsel dass man gar nicht
richtig in worte fassen kann dass man
das sozusagen dadurch löst dass man sagt
das universum ist aus einem unendlichen
geist zb hervorgegangen
bei meiner meinung nach ist gehört
passiert genau das was ich vorhin
angesprochen habe die einfachste
erklärung ist die beste man macht eine
zudem reetz dass man ohnehin schon hat
fügt man ein weiteres hinzu wie es gott
in die welt oder vor die welt gekommen
ja also man sagt es gibt das universum
ich weiß nicht wie es entstanden ist
dann gibt es noch gott und gott hat das
universum erschaffen das ein sehr viele
neue unbekannte die jetzt da sozusagen
in die gleichung kommen und da würde ich
sagen ist die sparsamere variante in
meinen augen die bessere auch wenn sie
lücken lässt und deshalb scheint mir so
zu sein wenn ich sage ich bin sie haben
natürlich recht naturalisten
sind oft physiker listen weil sie wir
sagen nicht nur die naturwissenschaft zu
sagen ist das maß an die wissenschaftler
das maß aller dinge sondern sie sagen
speziell die naturwissenschaft und noch
spezieller die physik ist das maß aller
dinge
und die lassen dann die psychologie oder
den geist aus jetzt frage ich mich ein
bisschen gemäßigter ist ich tendiere
dazu dienen etwas gemäßigter die
wissenschaften zusammen sind das maß
aller dinge da wird auch die psychologie
dazu dann scheint mir das doch eine
sparsamere annahme zu sein und nicht so
viel probleme mehr auf zu werfen wie der
radikale physical ist durch ein recht
geben der probleme hat zum beispiel
bewusst sein zurückkehren aber sie hat
stoppen bei einer zweiheit nämlich es
gibt einerseits materie und das bleibt
im letzten unerklärt und zweitens gibt
es für siege ist jedenfalls in gestalt
ist morgen als eines geistigen wesens
als eines ich subjekt und dabei bleiben
sie auch stehen ich gebe ihnen sogar zu
wenn wir die welt erklären wollen und
wenn wir philosophisch über die welt
nachdenken müssen wir bei bestimmten
dingen ansetzen
die wir dann in der tat ihrerseits nicht
mehr erklären und begründen können aber
wir müssen um es mal etwas polemisch zu
sagen wir müssen bei den richtigen
dingen enden und bei den richtigen
dingen enden heißt zum beispiel bei
etwas zu enden was uns erstens vertraut
ist und was wir nicht aufheben können
und was ist uns vertraut wir denken ja
dass es hier diesen tisch gibt dass es
also materielle objekte gibt das ist
doch selbstverständlich in der welt ich
würde sagen so ist ja gar nicht unsere
situation wir sind ja gar nicht mit
materie konfrontiert sondern wir sind
wiesen die so etwas wahrnehmen die aus
ihren wahrnehmungen schlüsse ziehen in
gestalt von theorien über
elementarteilchen und so weiter das
heißt dass wir als objekte da sind die
das materielle denken und auch noch
denken dass die geilste gewesen sind ist
der ausgangspunkt und ist das vertraute
und ist übrigens unhintergehbare denn
der der naturalist kann zwar sagen es
gibt und gibt eine vom geist und ab
einige materie was ich in gewisser weise
auch nicht bezweifle
und dann ist irgendwann der mensch
aufgetreten der mensch wird irgendwann
wieder verschwinden nicht dann war
materie unerkannt und gewürdigt einfach
vor sich hin und das entspricht aber gar
nicht unserer geistigen situation unsere
geistige situation ist dass wir unsere
perspektive als geistige wesen gar nicht
verlassen können sondern wir sind immer
nur mit unseren wahrnehmungen gedanken
und so weiter des materiellen
konfrontiert und deshalb schlage ich vor
enden wir doch enden wir doch an diesem
punkt der für uns nicht hinter geber ist
ich würde auch an den punkten ich würde
auch sagen vertraut sind wir mit unseren
eigenen bewusstsein führt sogar sagen
dass auch tiere bewusstsein haben
vielleicht nicht so einig perspektive
wie wir es haben aber wir sind ja
hervorgegangen aus sozusagen weniger
entwickelten lebensform und das
sicherlich bewusstsein nicht erst
gekommen als der mensch entstanden ist
eine evolution aber auch wenn ich
vertraut bin mit meinem eigenen
bewusstsein folgt für mich immer noch
nicht daraus dass ist einen unendlichen
geist lieben muss man das scheint mir
immer wieder diese zusatzeinnahmen zu
sein also ich würde das auch sagen es
wir sind vertrauten unserem bewusstsein
aber warum soll ich dann annehmen dass
es so etwas gibt wie ein unendliches
bewusstsein dass vor dem universum aber
stück weit auch wer trägt eine nicht die
beweislast um die interessantesten die
geschichte der philosophie betrachtet
dann ist es ja jetzt schon einige
jahrhunderte her aber trotzdem
es gab zeiten in denen landeten
philosophen auf den scheiterhaufen wir
denken an giordano bruno oder wurden
verfolgt dies - beispielsweise weil sie
sich gegen dogmen gewarnt haben also
philosophen die gesagt haben entweder
gott existiert nicht oder dieser gott
existiert nicht oder gewisse dogmen
existieren nicht die wurden angegriffen
heute scheint es ja umgekehrt zu sein
die philosophen die für die sache gottes
kämpfen und sich als gläubige outen sind
in der ganz krassen minderzahl
und sie sind ein bisschen im
philosophischen kreuzverhör
warum warum ist das so
ich würde sagen wie sie es gerade
beschrieben haben weil traditionell
hier an annahme die über die sozusagen
beobachtungs und erlebniswelt hinausgeht
dafür braucht man gute gründe das ist
halt schwieriger dafür zu argumentieren
das ist noch ein höheres wesen gewiss
nicht unmöglich aber es ist halt
schwieriger aufwendiger als zu sagen na
ja das was die erfahrungswissen
schafften und meine eigene erfahrung mir
präsentiert das ist die welt und darüber
hinaus gibt es nichts dann hat man so
eine art minimal annahme für die man
nicht so viele argumente braucht wie für
den schritt den man dann weitergeht
braucht es mut hp kämpft dieses buch zu
schreiben und würden sie auch wirklich
angegriffen haben kollegen gesagt
entschuldigung das sieht wirklich sozial
passagier halten dass einige kollegen
und auch einige freunde mehr oder
weniger für eine form von verrücktheit
also darüber beschwere ich mich gar
nicht ich will auf ihre frage noch mal
warum sich die zeiten geändert haben
eingehen wir haben vorhin gesagt es gibt
drei mögliche positionen nicht den
materialismus oder naturalismus den
dualismus und den idealismus und ich
finde es erstmal in der
geistesgeschichte der menschheit sehr
gut dass alle drei positionen
ausprobiert werden ausprobieren heißt
erst einmal man nimmt sie ernst man
durch denkt ihre konsequenzen man
vergleicht sich ihrer konsequenzen
miteinander und es macht gar nichts das
dass man nach dem lange zeit der gottes
gedanke selbstverständlich war und die
atheisten sich rechtfertigen mussten und
nicht nur rechtfertigen sondern auch auf
dem scheiterhaufen gelandet sind es
macht gar nichts sondern ist es sogar
eher erstrebenswert und gut gewesen dass
in der kultur entwicklung und
entwicklung der philosophie irgendwann
der naturalistische gedanke ernst
genommen wurde und durchdacht wurde dass
wir also eine kultur haben die mit
diesem gedanken ernst gemacht hat in
jeder hinsicht ernst gemacht hat das
ändert aber nichts daran wenn man über
die dinge nachdenkt dass sich
herausstellt die beiden anderen optionen
sind in wahrheit nicht vom tisch weil
die naturalistische position nicht so
glänzend und problemlos dasteht wie das
immer wieder hingestellt
und jeder der es ernsthaft dadurch denkt
muss sagen okay also der dualismus ist
denkbar und auch der idealismus ist
nehmen wir mal diese teekanne hierzu
haben sie ja hügel haben am anfang
bertrand russell bereits erwähnt der
ihnen ja zu wenig hinweise gegeben hat
dass das sie an ihn glauben könnten
der britische philosoph im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert hat er das
gedankenexperiment ehesten ins spiel
gebracht er ist nicht mit th sondern mit
zwei hatte ich ein bisschen darüber
lustig gemacht der test ist netter
nachbar der glaubt daran dass eine
solche teekanne zwischen mars und erde
kreist dies natürlich zu klein auf diese
distanz gesehen als dass man sie mit
irgendeinem teleskop sehen könnte der
test glaubt trotzdem daran welche
argumente gibt es jetzt daran zu glauben
oder nicht daran zu glauben dass der tee
ist muss man den einfach für verrückt
halten
herr hügel wie sie sind russell wendet
sich dagegen so naiven tees muss der so
was sagt wie es gibt da draußen ein
wesen dem sehr viele eigenschaften
zuschreibt aber sagt das ist im prinzip
unerkennbar und er sagt das ist
natürlich absolut dann könnte ich da von
der viele spielarten dient das spaghetti
monster ist relativ bekannten der
popkultur also atheisten die sagen sie
glauben dass spaghettimonster das aber
unsichtbar ist niemand kann als jemals
sehen oder das rosa einhorn das
unsichtbar ist und nicht gesehen werden
kann
das sind einfach sozusagen viele
versuche um zu zeigen dass bestimmte
form von tee es muss ja die sehr
konkrete vorstellungen haben von diesem
höheren wesen irgendwie absurd sind wenn
sie sagen das wesen hat alle diese
eigenschaften aber wir können sie nicht
erkennen wir können niemals wissen
und dann fragt man sich ja wieso machst
dann ob die annahme dass es diese
eigenschaften gibt der argumentative
tourismus ist natürlich anders weil er
nicht sagt es gibt da irgendwo draußen
eine teekanne sondern weil es da um die
logische möglichkeit geht und um sehr
allgemeine annahmen die erst mal nicht
für sich in sich schon mal
widersprüchlich sind und so habe ich
auch die teekanne irgendwie ein bisschen
einzumieten
das system in dem wir denken
immer noch wird nun einen neuen testen
wenn ich das noch kurz ausführen darf
warum ärgert dass philosophen potenziell
also wenn jetzt da leute hingehen und
sagen was hast du eigentlich für ein
problem glaube ich eben an eine teekanne
glaube ich eben an gott glauben an ein
spaghetti monster oder an frau holle
es gibt vielleicht dinge an die glaubt
man und man braucht doch gar nicht immer
für alles die von uns zu reden menschen
ja auch über über gott gott spüre ich
gott ist da draußen der entzieht sich
eben gerade der vernunft warum können
wir nicht am dinge glauben warum müssen
da die philosophen einen sozusagen
zurechtweisen
ich will das persönlich habe mich stört
das gar nicht wenn leute an alle
möglichen dinge glauben man muß nur
sichergehen dass sie davon nicht
irgendwelche substanziellen thesen dann
für das zwischenmenschliche
zusammenleben ableiten also und
zumindest glauben dass sie damit das
rechtfertigen können also wenn solange
die moralischen regeln nach denen wir
leben sollen selber nochmal diskutiert
werden dürfen können alle menschen alles
glauben
und natürlich wenn jemand das sagt und
in eine diskussion eintreten will das
ist oft macht nämlich die auf
beobachtung dann muss jemand der solche
anlagen macht auch bereit sein sich
argumente anzuhören die dagegen sprechen
wenn dann nur sowas sagt wie ich habe so
ein diffuses gefühl da ist noch mehr da
draußen oder ich jemand hilft mir oder
ich hab ein gesprächspartner
das darf man nicht in abrede stellen
jeder soll so viele gesprächspartner
oder wesen annehmen dürfen wie er will
aber es gibt ja auch schon diese art von
gottes details nennen kann
wahrscheinlich eben gerade nicht
don't work in der berühmte
rechtsphilosoph der vor ein paar jahren
gestorben ist religion ohne gott ohne
gott aber er ist natürlich kein test
aber der sagt ja ganz klar natürlich
alle menschen haben so was wie ein
ergriffen sein angesichts des
sternenhimmels wir hören die
matthäuspassion von johann sebastian
bach
wir betreten ein sakrales gebäude da
kommt so ein wohliges schaudern das in
formen von beweisen oder hinweise auf
transzendente was immer auch schon zu
unserem menschsein dazu gehört ist das
sind das figuren die in ihrer theologie
auch eine rolle spielen dass das
überhaupt nicht der weg den sie
beschreiten ich habe das buch nicht
thematisierte aber natürlich
gehört das dazu es gibt also als
philosoph können wir nur fragen kann man
gott denken wenn wir viel zeit hätten
würde ich gerne über die tkn herrn aber
sagen
das scheint mir alles unter niveau zu
sein das so zu betrachten der gottes
gedanke ist ein ganz anderer gedanke und
der es erst dann in dieser hinsicht zu
vergleichen mit dem erschließen von
elementarteilchen das ist nämlich auch
etwas sehr kompliziertes und schwieriges
die haben eigenschaften die die dinge
hier in dieser makroskopischen welt
überhaupt nicht haben ist das wollte ich
nur sagen man sollte das man sollte das
offene die wohl diskutieren aber
selbstverständlich ist es so die
tatsache dass die natur einen erhabenen
eindruck gemacht dass sie das der
sternenhimmel der kosmos auch etwas
geordnet ist es ja schon eine tortur
sprung ist für das wort kosmos etwas
geordnet ist es dass wir diese gesetze
erkennen können dass diese gesetze
symmetrie eigenschaften aufweisen das
spielt ja bei rock in eine ganz wichtige
rolle
das ist etwas wunderbares und darin kann
man selbstverständlich die handschrift
gottes sehen
ich würde allerdings sagen es gibt einen
anderen aspekt man kann zb ich bin zb
begeistert davon
von der schönheit der gleichung mit
denen man zb den elektromagnetismus
beschreibt was in vier wunderbare
mathematisch der wunderbaren
mathematische gleichungen aber wir
müssen natürlich hinzuzufügen das sind
dieselben gleichungen diese gleichungen
beschreiben gesetze die auch dazu führen
dass ein kind an leukämie erkrankt und
stirbt also man muss natürlich wenn man
so eine art naturreligion ohne gott
propagiert wird die geschichte
vollständig erzählen und wenn man die
geschichte vollständig erzählt dann muss
man über die übel und leiden in der
natürlich reden das sind wir bei der
theodizee leibnitz zwei bände versucht
der angesichts der übrigen der welt
diesen allwissenden allmächtigen gütigen
gott zu rechtfertigen
damit haben sich aber ja eigentlich doch
auch ein problem damit habe ich in der
tat ein problem wenn man einen vergleich
macht zwischen den verschiedenen
weltanschaulichen rahmen optionen die
wir haben ja muss man selbstverständlich
sagen was können die verschiedenen
positionen zu den übeln sagen und hier
gerät selbstverständlich der tourismus
in erklärungsnöte und in erklärung
schwierigkeiten aber sie sind nicht von
sie sind nicht von der art dass es nicht
vernünftige teil antworten in tees
tischer perspektive gibt es gibt eine
sehr interessante und sehr ausgefeilte
diskussion über die übel in der welt und
die wunden sie das problem
ich löse das problem so dass ich sage
wir verstehen erstens warum es
moralische übel gibt also weil wir nicht
das böse das böse warum es das böse gibt
weil wir freie wiesen sind und gott uns
auch will und geschaffen hat als freie
wesen was ich nicht erklären kann und
auch nicht verstehe ist das ausmaß an
physischen übeln dass wir in der welt
finden also übel wie naturkatastrophen
krankheiten usw dinge für die menschen
nun wirklich nachweislich nicht
verantwortlich zu machen sind die nicht
auf ihr konto gehen und das ist ein
problem das kann ich nicht kann der tee
ist nicht gut beantworten aber wir
sollten natürlich nicht die aus ihnen
die literatur da kommt der walter
benjamin bei ihnen zum zug
also das ist mit ein mensch verloren die
das heißt noch mal ein zusätzlicher
aspekt ich will nur sagen der naturalist
hat natürlich auch ein problem mit den
übeln und leiden in der welt auch er
muss dazu etwas sagen und möglicherweise
kann er gar nichts dazu sagen er muss
das einfach hinnehmen
er muss sagen ja die welt ist eben so
aber man könnte jetzt folgendermaßen
denken bevor ich nicht mit den übeln und
leiden hat finde
durch denke ich noch mal denke ich
überhaupt über das ganze der welt
richtig wenn ich zum beispiel
naturalistisch denke oder wenn nicht
realistisch denke oder wie ich wenn
nicht ist ich denke und das interessante
daran ist immer wie stellt sich die
sachlage im lichte der einen oder der
anderen rahmen annahme da und da ist es
eigentlich sollte aber abfinden
natürlich recht dass man sich wenn man
nicht an gott glaubt irgendwie damit
abfinden muss allerdings hat abfinden
mehrere lesarten ich würde sagen kein
atheist findet sich ja mit dem mit dem
leid in der welt dadurch ab dass er sagt
das ist einfach so sondern was wir alle
menschen versuchen mehr es gelingt uns
natürlich oft nicht und die ganze
geschichte spricht dagegen
wir versuchen ja dass die welt welt
irgendwie besser wird und ein indikator
könnte sein dass weltweit immerhin die
gewalt in den letzten jahrhunderten
abgenommen hat auch wenn die
grausamkeiten die es auf der welt gibt
heutzutage noch unvorstellbar sind ja
aber ich glaube nicht dass man sich sagt
man kann nicht sagen ein atheist findet
sich mit dem light ab indem er das
einfach akzeptiert aber muss natürlich
akzeptieren dass vergangenes leid nicht
mehr wieder gutzumachen ist also man
kann ich in der vergangenheit zurück
reisen und dann nicht glaubt dass ein
dass irgendwas wie ein jüngstes gericht
gibt dann ist das böse was passiert es
ist geschehen
aber ich frage mich immer bei denen bei
dem bei der theodizee frage ich mich
auch immer man kann natürlich sagen wenn
wir menschen frei sind also gott hat die
welt geschaffen ist allmächtig
wieso kann es böses geben naja eine
begründung kann ja sagen wir sind frei
wir sind an unserem schicksal ja zu
einem teil selbst schuld gott hat uns
die möglichkeit gegeben das gute zu
erkennen aber leider sind wir auch
fehlbare wesen und wir tun hat schlimme
dinge ein problem haben sie angesprochen
naturkatastrophen eine frage dem thema
stelle wochen hat uns gott nicht ein
bisschen vernünftiger gemacht ich meine
hätte doch sagen können na ja wir machen
den menschen er macht den menschen ein
bisschen weniger anfällig für
verlockungen weniger anfällig für
aggressionen für dominanzstreben und
diese ganzen neigungen die wir haben die
einfach zu leid und unglück führen und
daher gibt es aber ich auch irgendwie
keine richtige antwort drauf also wenn
wir vernünftig genug wären müssen ja
nicht allmächtig und selber auch als
vernünftig sein aber vernünftig
könnte man vielleicht auch schon viel
verhindern auch vielleicht vorher sehen
was es für naturkatastrophen geben
könnte zu einem gewissen teil tun wir
das natürlich aber warum sie wir da
nicht ein bisschen besser frage ich mich
einfach das machen wir mal noch ein
schritt ins ins praktische leben in die
frage was man könnte mit nun etwas
luhmann sagen was religion eigentlich
leistet was der glaube leistet sie haben
vorhin vom sternenhimmel gesprochen der
einen ergreifen kann oder gläubige
vielleicht eine spezifische art und
weise hat mit diesem sternenhimmel
umzugehen
aber es gibt ja auch viele menschen die
ganz generell sagen glaube gibt ihnen
halt können sie das verstehen erheben
kann ich absolut verstehen dass gibt es
eine ganz große bandbreite an emotionen
und stimmungen die mit dem glauben
assoziiert sind also einmal dieses
erhabenheit gefühl wenn man blickt in
den sternenhimmel
dann gibt es so was wie ein geborgenheit
gefühl das ist vielleicht so was was man
auch hat als kind wenn man von seinen
eltern den arm genommen wird
es gibt andere phänomene wie zum
beispiel dass menschen das gefühl haben
eine person ist in ihrer nähe
manche haben das gefühl ihre körper
grenzen verschwimmen es wird oft im
buddhismus und bei yoga praktiken
berichtet also leute die das sehr lange
machen wenn die meditieren dass sie das
gefühl haben sie werden eins mit allem
all diese phänomene sind real und die
kann man auch untersuchen und ich glaube
auch den berichten
ich glaube nur dass man schon haben die
nicht ich hatte noch nicht sowas in der
richtung bisher nie ich bin da sogar
noch ach so ja erhabenheit gefühl habe
ich oft ja aber ich glaube man muss
vorher schon religiös sein um dann zu
sagen das spricht dafür dass jetzt ein
höheres wesen existiert ich würde nicht
eine abrede stellen das ist unglaublich
ist ins universum zu schauen sich dann
vorzustellen was ist was kommt dahinter
und man sich diese großen größen auch
klar macht ja diese 6 milliarden jahre
und unser leben ist so klein also diesem
moment habe ich auch ich würde es nur
nicht religion nennt man kann das machen
nur dann finde ich verwendet man den
religions- oder den glauben begriff zu
weit dann macht man fast jeden menschen
der einmal gestaunt hat über das
universum zu einem gläubig menschen
wir haben auch ein paar passanten
gefragt was für sie persönlich es
bedeutet an gott zu glauben dass ihr
leben
hannes kühlt das irgendeinen gott gott
berufen also gar nicht das bedürfnis ist
aber nämlich antrag war da eine größere
macht merkt dass das positive dominiert
das richtig gehört egal wie vor allem
und renault logan bailly natura lagen
und sowas ist irgendwie ein positiv
bewegen
es gab nicht um rechtliche wert des
lehrers und den moralischen wert war wie
die biblischen sich das nachstellen
es geht um respekt so der mensch ist
gerade im respekt vor der natur das ist
für mich ein zentraler hebel braucht es
gut für die moral
ich glaube ich auch nicht das kann man
glaube ich leicht daran sehen dass es
atheisten gibt die einen sagen
atheistischen sinne frommes und gutes
leben führen ohne an gott zu glauben ist
natürlich umgekehrt so dass sehr
gläubige menschen hängt natürlich von
der region ab wer glaubt die menschen
oft auch sehr empathisch sind und sehr
hilfsbereit sind ja also man zum
beispiel beim christentum an die
diakonie denkt oder an die ganzen
hilfswerke aber es hat sich auch leuten
sehr gläubige menschen die sehr
fanatisch sind also insofern kann man da
glaube ich keine direkte korrelation
finden trotzdem hat zum beispiel gregor
gysi der fraktionsvorstand vorsitz der
linken im bundestag hat mal gesagt
obwohl er selber nicht gläubig ist
fürchtet er die gottlose gesellschaft
gibt so etwas wie einen atheistischen
trittbrettfahrer der profitiert davon
dass andere glauben
naja er denkt dann wahrscheinlich an so
an hedonistische sehr materialistisch
orientierte menschen die sehr wenig über
ihr leben und über andere nachdenken und
dann glaubt er wahrscheinlich dass er
sozusagen keine werte geben kann oder
keine echte auseinandersetzung mit
werten wenn keiner mehr an gott glaubt
ich glaube dass die entwicklung in denen
in europa eigentlich dagegen spricht wir
sind immer und werden immer ein
ungläubiger also man so umfragen sieht
die leute die wirklich sagen ich bin
sicher dass gott glaubt die sind eine
absolute minderheit mittlerweile es gibt
einen großteil von leuten die sub anti
ist das sind die sowas sagen wie ich
glaube eine höhere macht aber nicht mehr
wirklich sich ernsthaft mit dem glauben
auseinandersetzen zum beispiel mit dem
christentum aber insgesamt ist in
deutschland zum beispiel die
kriminalitätsrate konstant gesungen es
gibt natürlich dazwischen keine direkte
korrelation aber es wäre es komisch zu
sagen je weniger glauben wir haben das
so amoralisch oder chaotischer wird die
gesellschaft also das kann man wirklich
nicht beobachten die sich hoffen hat
dass mehr menschen gläubig werden
so ist es wie so eine privatsache sie
persönlich haben dazu gefunden aber was
die anderen machen eine privatsache ist
das nicht sondern das ist einfach eine
interessante frage über die wir in einer
gesellschaft diskutieren sollten als
eine interessante und wichtige frage und
welche entscheidung am ende getroffen
wird das ist in der tat eine persönliche
entscheidung und ich kann gut leben mit
einer pluralistischen gesellschaft in
der ezb ist auf dem gebiet der
philosophie naturalisten gibt
journalisten und idealisten gibt ich
glaube dass eine gesellschaft aber
natürlich in dem sinne davon profitiert
wenn es wenn bestimmte optionen zum
beispiel wie soll man mit den übeln und
leiden in der welt umgehen wie soll man
die übel und leiden in der welt
betrachten denn bestimmte optionen
weiterhin auch präsent sind sagen wir im
weitesten sinne in der
gesellschaftlichen diskussion im
gesellschaftlichen moralischen diskurs
wobei ich herrn hübel vollkommen
zustimmen ich glaube wir brauchen die
religion nicht und den gottes gedanken
nicht wenn es um die frage geht was ist
böse und was ist gut was ist recht und
was ist unrecht und zweitens bestimme
ich herrn hübel auch vollkommen zu wenn
er betont dass selbstverständlich
gläubige gott gläubige menschen nicht
die moralisch besseren personen sind ja
da wird ja auch im namen der religion
gemordet und so
richtig ist denn gott für sie persönlich
notwendig oder zumindest eine gute sache
wenn es um die sinnfrage geht stiftet
gott sind sie 16 uhr
ich überlege es dann überlegen sie mal
fragen herrn teams zuerst ja weil das
der kern sogar das tourismus ist kern
des tourismus ist ja die vorstellung
dass allem in der behält die geistige
wirklichkeit gottes zu grunde liegt gott
ist eine schöne theologische formel ist
die alles bestimmende wirklichkeit oder
der urgrund der wirklichkeit und hier
wird von vornherein dieser urgrund der
wirklichkeit als etwas sinnvolles
gedacht und als etwas was im prinzip
sinnvoll nachvollzogen werden kann und
das ist eben eine ganz an ein ganz
anderer ausgangspunkt als wir uns sagt
na ja es gibt da diese komischen
merkwürdigen elementarteilchen und aus
diesen elementarteilchen und ihrem
zusammenwirken nach sinnlosen in diesem
sinne sinnfreien sagen wir besser so
nach sinnfreien gesetzen entsteht alles
dann färbt diese art der
entstehungsgeschichte der sinnfreien
entstehungsgeschichte im grunde genommen
auf uns als geiste gewesen ab weil wir
dann sagen müssen in kern betrachtet und
unterm strich betrachtet sind wir selber
sinnlose sinnfreie zufallsprodukte
fliegen ist ein material das klingt
natürlich alles philosophisch sehr
durchdacht aber wenn ich die sinnfrage
stellen dann stelle ich mir sowas vor
wie die berühmte situation bei sagte er
steht an der raumstation und plötzlich
fällt die welt in sich zusammen man hat
den eindruck es ist alles sinnlos ich
bin sinnlos was hier läuft das sinus
hilft ihnen in diesem moment dieses
relativ wolke generöse denken über gott
wie sie jetzt gerade formuliert haben
gibt ihnen das dann einen sinn oder
kennen sie diese situation gar nicht
doch diese situation kann ich
selbstverständlich und es gibt mir
jedenfalls es stärkt mich wenn ich als
philosoph erkennen kann dass der gottes
gedanke ein vernünftiger gedanke
ist die man ernst nehmen kann und ich
brauche dazu nicht allen wissen was
sowieso eine illusion wäre man könnte
den gottes gedanken in irgendeiner weise
definitiv beweisen
aber ich finde es ausgesprochen
aufmunternd ausgesprochen aufbauend wenn
man sagen kann du musst nicht unbedingt
zu der position greifende die eben
darauf hinaus läuft eigentlich gibt es
nur materie sinnfreie möglichkeit über
die sinnfragen nachzudenken wie zum
ersten mal gespannt
also ich glaube ich dass es so etwas
gibt wie einen sinn der über mein leben
hinausgeht was ja dann oft wenn sie das
jetzt ansprechen erwartet wird man so
fragte was ist der sinn des lebens das
ist ja eine frage die philosophen
relativ selten eigentlich diskutieren in
der weise und da glauben ja die menschen
es gibt so etwas was über mich hinaus
geht ja das ganze universum irgendwie so
sinnvoll eingerichtet ist es gibt
natürlich so dieses phänomen das man
sich selber fragt was mache ich mit
meinem eigenen leben so und ich scheue
tiere oft zwischen zwei positionen hin
und her hat was die da geschrieben haben
dass man so denkt es wird nichts von
einem übrig bleiben
das kann sehr beklemmend seien ja und
auch so wird das gar nicht ganz gut
beschrieben dass die welt so in sich
zusammenfällt also phänomenal von innen
erlebt fühlt sich das manchmal so an
gleichzeitig habe mir jetzt aber öfter
auch mal kraft gegeben weil ich mir
gedacht habe wenn ich wenn die welt wenn
er alles irgendwann vorbei ist warum
soll ich jetzt nervös sein wenn ich ein
referat in der schule hätte ja manchmal
dann vor dem referat habe ich wieder
vergessen und da war ich wieder trotzdem
nervös aber ich habe so ein bisschen
spazieren manchmal geht mir das ein
bisschen kraft und manchmal finde ich
das frustrierend und wie gesagt mich
überzeugen leider keine bisher noch
keine theologischen argumente so dass
ich da sozusagen mehr sinn finden kann
als aber nicht so weit gehen wie
berghammer ja eigentlich gesagt hat in
seinem mythos des sisyphos der gläubige
der ist eigentlich feige der anerkennt
nichts das ist einfach darum geht diesen
stein zustimmung der ort hat wieder nach
unten
das ich glaube das hängt davon ab von
welcher art der gläubiger es gibt
sicherlich gläubige die sogar eine art
selbstverleugnung leben und sich nicht
konfrontieren damit dass der tod
vielleicht das ende darstellen könnte
und auch nicht erleben daran ausrichten
aber es gibt natürlich viele die wenn
sie sich mit gott beschäftigen sich
gerade auch mit der endlichkeit des
lebens beschäftigen und das in einem
engen zusammenhang sehen und die
konfrontieren sich natürlich mit ihrer
endlichkeit ja was man dann am ende ist
es auch eine frage der temperamente ob
man am ende überzeugt ist dass
gottesglaube eine möglichkeit ist die
einen vielleicht beruhigt oder ob man da
irgendwie nicht für empfänglich ist da
wird es würde ich würde ich mich eher
beschreiben vielleicht hat das auch gar
nichts mehr auf einer argumentativen
ebene zu tun sondern ist vielleicht
irgendwo anders angesiedelt ja dass man
das nicht mehr argumentativ einholen
kann ist ja oft so dass man zwar für
dinge argumentieren kann aber irgendwann
wenn man immer weiter zurückgeht an
einem punkt ist wo man nur sagen kann
wir haben sie hat sagt ist so oder halte
ich für plausibel oder unplausibel dass
er nicht noch mal begründen kann
verlassen diese bemerkung von camille so
sehr ich kann die schätze und ernst
nehme unpassend denn feigheit von faika
darf nur dann geredet werden wenn schon
klar ist dass die naturalistische
position die richtige position ist und
damit wiederum angst an der gläubige in
der tat ein traumtänzer den den
realitäten nicht ins auge blicken will
und dann müsste man in der tat vor den
atheisten und vika müde den hut ziehen
und sagen die sind die einzigen die den
mut haben ihrem eigenen leben einen sinn
zu geben und an ihrem eigenen leben
einen sinn abzutrotzen obwohl sie teil
einer welt sind die im kern sinnfrei und
absolut ist aber solange die anderen
optionen gar nicht widerlegt sind
sie habe schon herr tätig haben gerne
das letzte wort ich gebe ihnen das
letzte wort in dem ich nämlich noch
einsatz bringen möchte aus ihrem buch
ich möchte damit aufhören mit diesem
zitat es gab schon einmal zeiten da hat
metaphysik die denkenden getröstet
es waren beileibe nicht die
schlechtesten oder wahrheit' fernsten
zeiten der philosophie ihr letzter satz
im buch
ob das stimmt oder nicht darüber haben
wir diskutiert wir haben damit gerungen
ich danke ihnen für nächsten sonntag
reist mein kollege juri steiner zurück
in die zukunft
am 21 oktober 2015 wird es nämlich so
weit sein
wir kommen genau an dem tag an an dem
microsoft ocs in dem film back to the
future in einer zeitmaschine in die
zukunft heißt sf zwei zeigt aus diesem
anlass nächste woche die kinofilme und
wir nehmen sie mit auf eine
philosophische zeitreise und diskutieren
die faszination von science fiction und
von zukunftsvisionen
wir freuen uns auf sie bis dahin eine
gute woche
[Musik]